[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in this video we'll be addressing the
question what happened
to harry potter's grandparents who were
they how did they die
james and lily potter were murdered by
voldemort at the very young age of 21.
the films sort of paint a different
picture in that the actors portraying
them
are seemingly much older than this i
think that when most people find out
just how young james and lily actually
were
they're usually a bit surprised so if
james and lily were only 21
it should be very safe to assume that
some of harry's grandparents would still
be alive
jk rowling has stated and we've seen
that witches and wizards can live
for a very long time much longer than a
usual human
so it always seemed unusual that harry
wouldn't have a single grandparent
after all he should have four let's
start with lily's parents
the evans the books have stated that
both of lily's parents died
normal michael deaths without going into
any detail
we know that they both died sometime
between 1971
and 1981 because in 1971 they saw lily
after hogwarts
at platform nine and three quarters and
in 1981
lily was murdered we know them to be
dead at this point
it's unusual that they would have died
in this time frame and i'm not really
sure what constitutes a normal michael
death
it definitely isn't old age because they
would have been far too young
so if it wasn't old age what's a normal
death
cancer heart attack it's really hard to
say
provided that all of the information we
have on their deaths groups them
together
that they were so young i suspect some
foul play lily and james potter were
both very outgoing witches and wizards
joining the order of the phoenix and
actively participating in the fight
against evil
this meant that they were very much on
the radar of the death eaters
in the harry potter films we've seen
many instances of death eaters
tyrannizing muggle london and attacking
muggles
so why would lily's parents be an
exception my theory is that because
lily was so prominent in the fight
against evil having defied voldemort
three times
she made her family a target because her
parents were both mongols
they would have had no means of
defending themselves and the death
eaters
could have visited them and ended their
lives instantly
in a deleted scene from harry potter and
the deathly hallows
harry approaches petunia and says the
following in reference to the death
eaters
they'll torture you if they think for a
moment that you know where i'm going
they'll stop at nothing to which she
responds you think i don't know what
they're capable of
to me this implies that petunia knows
more about the wizarding world than
previously implied
she's initially painted as a little bit
ignorant towards everything going on
but really i think that she knows
exactly what's happening because she's
experienced it before
with not only lilly but her parents as
well this would also explain her adamant
hatred
of everything magical so that's my
theory this of course contradicts what
jk rowling has said
so take from it what you will but i just
found myself unhappy with her original
answer
what do you guys think okay moving on to
james's parents
james's parents were flemont and
euphemia potter they were both
pure blood witches and wizards that came
from affluence
fleemont was the ancestor of linford of
stinchcombe who invented an extensive
number of potions
fleemont himself was also an avid potion
maker and created the sleek easy's hat
potion
which quadrupled the family's gold
unlike lily's mother
euphemia became pregnant with james much
later in her life
and gave birth to him in march 1960.
while their deaths were not particularly
interesting
either there is a little bit more
information that has been provided
in one of my last videos i discussed all
of the wizarding diseases
epidemics and ailments one in particular
dragon pox
was the cause of both of their deaths
dragon pox is a contagious disease
occurring in wizards and witches that
can be fatal
it is similar in nature to the muggle
chicken box it leaves little pock marks
on the skin
and can result in a lasting greenish
tinge in some cases it can result in a
green and purple rash between the toes
and sparks that come out of the nostrils
when the patient sneezes
it sort of makes sense that they would
have both died from this because they
were vulnerable and old
and the disease is very contagious
perhaps because of their age
they weren't able to properly fight the
disease similar to the way that the
chickenpox virus
intensifies and develops as shingles in
adults
i don't have a theory for how they died
because i'm somewhat satisfied with it
however i would have loved to have seen
heard more about these characters in the
books and films
and that concludes the video i hope you
guys enjoyed it what do you think of my
first theory
let me know in the comment section down
below until next time remember
there is plenty to be learned even from
a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
you